[MUSIC]
Would you prefer if this was
a interview on bikes right now?
>> Absolutely not [LAUGH].
>> Have you ever done a class for
600 people?
>> Never.
>> Would you want to try?
>> Yes.
>> Okay [LAUGH]
>> Right after this meet in the quad.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Ruth, thank you so much for being here,
for coming to Stanford, for being a part
of the View From The Top program.
We have a lot to cover.
>> We do, thank you.
>> If it's all right,
can we just jump right in?
>> Let's do it.
>> So I want to take us back,
all the way back.
You described some very key
moments in your childhood.
Being pivotal to the successes and
challenges and
the obstacles you ultimately overcame
both personally and professionally.
And a lot of that comes from dance.
What role did dance
play in your childhood?
>> It played a huge role.
I discovered ballet classes
when I was eight years old.
My mother decided it would be a good idea.
She said I was getting a belly.
Thanks, Mom.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so she put me in dance class.
Little did she know she basically
created a monster in that.
I just took to it immediately and
there was something about dancing that
just made me feel great, it was an escape.
And back to my mother,
she was a difficult woman.
She was narcissistic,
there wasn't much room for
me, there wasn't much room for my voice.
And so in retrospect, when I look back,
it made sense that I got so
addicted to dancing, because it became my
way of expressing myself without words,
without a voice.
>> And I think, in your story,
there's so much grit and
perseverance, that I think, explains
a lot of where you were able to get.
And you described overcoming challenges
like the relationship with your mother.
That often get overlooked when we talk
about the typical type of challenges here
in Silicon Valley, or in leadership,
or in entrepreneurship.
Could we spend a minute just
on those types of setbacks?
What was it like, even in a household and
in your relationship with your mother,
trying to
fit into someone else's definition of
success on such a personal context.
>> Well it had major repercussions for me,
because growing up with
a mother like that.
Your self esteem is not
going to be very high.
And if you're always deferring to someone.
And that person is always telling
you that they know more than you do.
It would make sense, it would be very
hard to build any kind of confidence.
So, that kind of really
spelled out my future.
And I'm a huge proponent of therapy and
we might get to that later.
But it was really the work that
I did in therapy that helped me
the most in terms of discovering who I am?
Why I am who I am?
And how to build the confidence to which
had gotten me to where I have gotten to.
>> And just staying on that point for
a minute.
You described in your
memoir that years later,
after launching very successful brands and
being a very successful entrepreneur in
almost any dimension that you
look at entrepreneurship from.
You were divorced and not yet
remarried and every winter, was it,
your mother would write a card saying
here's to a better year next year.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes.
>> And I know that seems extreme,
but when I read it,
I felt that that actually
is quite relatable.
There are people in all of our lives
where they demand something that
we feel we have to go up hold.
What was it like struggling
through that version of success?
That wasn't your own.
>> I mean, it was part generational.
I would say for my mother, but actually
the words were same thing every year.
Hopefully this year will be a better year.
That was after I started soulcycle.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So [LAUGH] when I say generational
what she meant every year when she wrote
these cards was i hope you find a man.
And I find it interesting to
myself that it took me a long time
after divorce to really settle settle
into a relationship with a man.
And I don't know, if I subconsciously
knew that I really shouldn't
go that route I really need to figure out
myself first before that falls into place.
>> And going right there to that moment in
life where you described being divorced
with two young daughters, I think they
were six years old, is that right?
>> Six, mm-hm.
>> What was going through your mind
as the next step, both personally and
then professionally,
it seems like would follow later.
>> Honestly, Mike, I had no idea.
I was Fish out of water.
I made this difficult decision
to leave the marriage.
Six year old twin girls in tow.
I was now a single mother didn't
have much on the financial front and
had to figure out my life again.
Having no idea how to even start and
that was when I found Spinning.
>> Walk us through that because today,
Spinning is, do we have any Soul Cycle
fans or Fly Will folks now.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Wow.
Thank you, that's amazing.
>> So today at it.
It is part of a lexicon,
it's in our culture and society,
but what year was it when
you started Spinning?
What was the landscape like because,
I imagine, it's very different than today?
>> So, I was, again,
newly out of a marriage,
embarking on this entirely
foreign new life.
And when you're going through a trauma,
one thing that I learned that's really
important is to take care of yourself and
stay healthy and strong.
And so I had a gym membership
at what was the Reebok Club on the Upper
West Side of Manhattan at the time.
And it was this beautiful
full-service gym that offered
every kind of group fitness you could
imagine, swimming pool, basketball court.
Really incredible place and I was able
to keep my gym membership with the divorce
and so I went there every day.
And I used to see the spin classes going
on and I found it very intriguing.
It was kind of a floor to
ceiling glass room, dark.
Room was full the sound of
the wheels club music blaring.
And I thought, that looks interesting but,
I was intimidated and
didn't know if I could really get
myself in there by myself and try it.
But I did.
And literally within the first class,
I knew that this was
something beyond exercise,
it felt like an experience for me.
It was a cathartic experience.
I felt that in the 45
minutes from beginning to end
there was almost a mini-transformation.
I got off the bike at the end of
the class and felt empowered, and felt
that I could really conquer my day and
the challenges that presented themselves.
>> As a quick time out to that I love
how in business school we do cases and
courses and six month learning programs to
try to have a light bulb moment that you
got getting on a bike one day.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> [LAUGH] Immediately.
>> Sounds like you took the shortcut.
>> [LAUGH] Thanks for that perspective.
>> Any time.
So, you get into Spinning.
It sounds like you learned
a lot about yourself first.
It wasn't a lightbulb moment, necessarily,
to, I need to go create a brand.
What did you find out when you did some
of the soul searching that seemed to come
from getting into the bike.
>> It really helped me realize how
much strength I needed to build.
And again,
there was something about this that
allowed me to recognize that this was
the way that I was going to do it and
it It just showed me
the importance of confidence and
believing in myself and
believing in my ideas.
And that my mother really
didn't know everything.
>> And that type of learning,
I think in a school like the GSP,
where there's a very touchy feely
mentality to approaching business,
that resonates I'm sure
with us in the audience.
But can you break it down to
what that actually meant for
going later into business and how you
applied some of that personal learning
into actually making a business around it?
>> Well, I really focused a lot on
my experience and how it helped me.
And very quickly,
I realized everybody has trauma.
Everybody has problems and
challenges in their life.
I saw what it did for me, and I so
believed in it that I just wanted to
share my experience with everyone else.
And I wanted everyone else to have
the same chance to empower themselves.
And so,
that was one of the motivating forces in
my getting to where I got to with
this concept of spinning, so, yeah.
>> Do you remember that conversation
you had where it all of a sudden
started to come together with
your co-founders at the time or
your would-be co-founders
in starting SoulCycle?
>> One of the co-founder's
approached me with the idea.
It was an idea I dreamed about, but
never had the capital, and she did.
And so, she clearly,
she was a fan of mine,
a big rider in my class, and
clearly recognized my passion for it.
She didn't know anything about teaching
spin or what went into it, and so
she depended on me to be the face of
the business and to provide the method.
And so she definitely appreciated it.
>> And as the discussions got going
you write and I quote, it had been
a quarter century since I gave up on my
dream to become a professional dancer.
This is on the brink of starting a brand
at the time, a fledging start up.
>> Yes.
>> What's going through your mind
the night before you start SoulCycle?
>> The night before we opened?
>> Yeah.
>> A lot of pride and
appreciation really for
everything that lead up to it.
We hear this a lot, but I lived it, and
it's so true that everything we do in our
life and everything that creates this path
that we take contributes to where we land.
And you brought up the dance
classes before, they so
tied in to the spin class that
I eventually helped to create.
And when I say that, what I mean is I was
obsessed with music from an early age.
And through dance classes,
I learned so much about music and
different genres of music.
Being a dancer, I choreograph to music.
I knew how to move to music and,
really, to some extent,
what I did was I just transfer
that experience on to a bike.
The discipline it takes to be a dance
student and to grow up as a dancer and
become a professional dancer,
that also transferred to the spin class.
When I started SoulCycle, we decided that
people should applaud after the class.
The instructor puts a lot into it,
especially when
you're going into a boutique experience,
you're paying up for it.
And you're paying for
an instructor spending two hours the night
before making his or her playlist.
And the applause is also for each other,
and for encouraging the community.
I mean, that's just a simple thing
that I learned from dance class.
And the other really key ingredient
to the success of boutique
fitness is the personal connection
that we would make with our riders.
And again,
no different from a dance class.
If I was in a dance class,
and my dance teacher said beautiful job,
Ruth, that took me through my day.
That made my day, and so, in a spin class
if you point out someone in the class,
if you make that personal connection,
they're coming back the next day.
>> So you start SoulCycle and,
plot twist, it works!
>> [LAUGH]
>> What did you learn from
that bootstrapping experience?
Because it wasn't that you went out,
you raised a lot of money, figured it out.
In fact,
we can get to the growth part later.
You were against expanding super fast and
getting off to the races.
You described a moment where in
your first center, I believe,
they wouldn't allow you to put signage
on the outside of the street entrance.
So you made it a cool have-to-know-someone
thing to walk through a gym and
get to the back near the exit-
>> [LAUGH]
>> To find the SoulCycle gym.
What were the learnings there from doing
it yourself and not raising capital?
>> Well, truthfully,
that was completely luck.
We signed a lease and
it was after we signed the lease that
the landlord said, by the way, no signage.
And we thought, my god,
what are we going to do?
And, because we were in the back of the
building, you can see us from the street.
And Elizabeth, one of my co-founders,
came up with the idea of just putting this
rickshaw outside, painting it yellow and
putting the name of our business
on it to attract attention.
But, again,
it eventually became just what you said,
people had to know about it
to to go there, and again,
completely unintentional but
it took on this kind of cool factor.
And you had to, you had to know
someone to know that it was there.
And in terms of learning lesson, I mean
that one, we had no idea but it worked.
And it's interesting,
I believe a lot in kind of
trickle down theory in
that the aura that you
create in your business has a lot to do
with who's at the top and the founders.
And, eventually, the partnership didn't
work out, and the truth is my two
co-founders were similar to each other,
but very different from me.
And I feel that the business took
on a lot of their personality.
Interestingly, when I started
Flywheel with two men,
the dynamic was completely different.
There was a certain respect
that the three of us had for
each other, respect for
each other's areas of expertise, and
we created a very
different aura at Flywheel.
And to summarize it,
I would always talk about
SoulCycle eventually becoming
a very exclusive feeling,
having a very exclusive feeling while
Flywheel had a very inclusive feeling.
We were about including everyone,
every shape, size and color.
SoulCycle took on a certain,
I'm blanking on the word,
but there was like a prestige
about going to SoulCycle.
And, again, no judgement here, it worked,
and obviously, SoulCycle became huge.
And so both personalities worked,
but they were just very different.
>> Can you talk a little
bit more about partnership?
I feel like when you decide to go
after something who you go in with is
probably the most critical piece.
This seemed, as you described it,
somewhat happenstance,
as you were approached by
one of the co-founders.
Where was the tension, ultimately,
in terms of thinking about growth,
what you all wanted?
What were the key learnings from that?
>> Really important question and
I get this all the time about
choosing partners in business.
And the bottom line is, obviously,
there's no guarantee ever.
Sometimes, I think about the fact that
My two co-founders of SoulCycle are two
women who I didn't know for
a long time and I thought, well,
maybe you should only go into business
with someone you do know for a long time.
But that's not the case either.
I actually just heard a story of two
friends who started a business and
knew each other for 25 years and
sure enough, they start the business.
Money gets involved,
the relationship fell apart and
the business partnership dissolved.
But what I learned was
it really helps to know yourself when
it comes to picking partners and
the truth is when I made the agreement
to go into business with these two
co-founders I didn't know myself, I really
hadn't done that kind of exploration.
And what I ended up doing was
I ended up with two partners who
were very much like my mother.
And they were two people that I,
my knee jerk was to defer to them.
To really let them overpower me and
to not have a voice,
I very easily slipped into that role.
And as a result,
the partnership fell apart.
And obviously,
that was a huge learning lesson for me,
a huge light bulb moment for me.
The other very obvious one was,
have really good legal protection, when
you go into a partnership in a business.
And I didn't.
And unfortunately,
I paid a big toll for that.
>> I appreciate the vulnerability,
because that's not often a takeaway
that people would want to share, so.
Going into Fly Wheel, which,
a lot of people when they hear your story,
they think of SoulCycle, or
they think of Fly Wheel,
they don't think that you
actually were behind both.
And you described Fly Wheel as
your first true business venture.
>> Yes.
>> Can you walk us through that transition
of leaving Soul?
I believe there was a stint
as an instructor for
soul,
>> Yes.
>> Which must have been weird.
>> I have to take a deep breath for
this answer.
I, our Separation Agreement was signed and
I was packing up my things to leave.
And one of my SoulCycle co founders looked
at me and said, where are you going?
And I looked at her like she had three
heads and I said, where am I going?
I'm leaving.
What do you mean you're leaving?
We thought you'd just be
an instructor is what she said to me.
And I don't even think I answered and
I turned around and started walking out,
and she kind of yelled to me as I
was walking out and she said, okay,
well just promise me that whatever other
offers you get will you come back to me?
Because I'll top that offer and we really
want you to be here as just an instructor.
And I don't even think I turned around and
I left.
And I got out there and here I was now
a single mom of two girls in high school.
You know,
not in a very strong position financially
and I went out there to see
what I was going to do next and
the reality was it was still
very early in the industry and
there were no other boutique
businesses at that point.
So, it really meant that I would have to
go back to one of the big box gyms and
teach classes for 40 bucks a class,
and I couldn't do it.
And so I went back.
I went back to her and I said,
okay, well, I got this offer.
And then sure enough,
she topped the offer very generously.
And I decided to do it, and
it was one of the hardest decisions I
ever made, and I did it for two years.
And every day I walked in to teach class,
I would have to look at both of them.
And I always say I probably grew
a grey hair every single day, and
it was torturous and it never got
any less torturous for two years.
But what happened was is I would walk in
and then I would get on my podium and
get on my bike and
there I was in front of all of my people
that I brought in to this business,
all the customers.
And they didn't know what happened,
and that helped a little bit.
Eventually they did, obviously.
But I would hit the play button,
my class would start.
And all of that negativity would
just go away for 45 minutes,
because I was just up there doing what I
do, which was connecting with my people.
They connected with me.
And we all had this cathartic
experience together, and
that's what got me through it.
Lastly, it was the summer of
2009 where I was teaching
a SoulCycle class, and it was then that I
met my future co-founder of Fly Wheels.
So If I hadn't been there,
I guess that never would've happened.
>> And right before meeting the would-be
founder of Flywheel, was there a moment,
because I think we tend to glorify
entrepreneurship as a no-brainer, must do,
don't look back, was there a moment
where you did look back and
you think I'm now caring for
a family solely on my shoulders?
This venture didn't work out and
it's a painful next two years.
Did you ever think about what life could
have been had you not taken that risk?
>> The risk with?
>> Soulcycle?
>> No, because I knew that
despite the negativity and
the trauma, I learned a lot, and
there were so many positive parts of it.
So no, I didn't regret it at all.
>> Going into Fly Wheel,
you're now at a point where you have
pioneered spinning and spin classes,
and that sense of community, and
you've built a brand around it once.
What did you feel like you could do
different in a space that you defined and
built already?
And now what would be a competitor?
>> Well my co-founder of Fly Wheel
made it very easy because he came up
with this idea of attaching
technology to the bike and
bringing this little computer
screen to the bike so that we could
finally measure exactly what we were doing
on the bike, how hard we were working,
what our resistance levels were,
how fast we were going.
And I knew that that would change
the experience significantly and
I doubted it in the beginning
because Soulcycle for me was so
much about the mindful component of
the ride and I thought, I don't know if we
have to focus on numbers we might
compromise the mindful component that's so
important to me and they just
begged me just get on the bike and
just go in there by yourself and and
work with it and see what you think.
And I did and
in that period of time, 40 minutes,
I knew this was going to be a game changer
because I could still do the mindful part
and have the numbers and I just felt like
this was taking it to the next level.
>> You described that your partners had
a different approach about in terms of
personality, but there's also a business
nugget where they felt that you could
actually grow the business by attracting
folks who otherwise wouldn't be cyclers or
spin goers.
What was that process like of
actually identifying a new market
audience where there wasn't one already?
This business is,
this type of business is honestly so
word of mouth for the entire time
that I was at Soul Cycle and
Flywheel, we never advertised once.
So again, it always came back
to connecting with people.
And I connected with the Flywheel
clientele pretty much in the same way I
did with the SoulCycle clientele and it
was just about making [COUGH] excuse me.
Making it personal and
make making people feel noticed.
At the end of the day that's what,
that's what we all want.
>> An interesting counter
balance to that as you described
that empathy should be in moderation
when going forward in business.
Which also runs counter to a lot of the
things we hear about especially today and
how do you lead with empathy?
Build a business around empathy.
You obviously have a product and a service
that made people feel a certain way.
But you also cautioned to use
it in moderation, why is that?
>> Sometimes it can get you into trouble.
[LAUGH] We, we were very big on empathy.
And it helped us in terms of the culture
we built with our employees, and
with our customer base.
And so I'm going to talk about
the positive part first,
which is again making everyone feel
important, making our maintenance
person feel as important as someone
on the executive leadership team.
By doing that, everybody has
this desire for the business to be
successful, and that's what you want.
You want everyone to be as
motivated as you are as a founder,
and sure enough,
that was a great way to get that.
Sometimes when you get too personal,
then, it could,
you know,
the business part can be compromised and
you get too much into the weeds and
I would recommend that.
But especially, again,
in this business because with instructors,
you're dealing with a very creative,
ego-driven group, and
that can be a slippery slope sometimes.
>> To zoom out a little bit,
you look at the brands that you
successfully built and led.
With SoulCycle and
Flywheel I was in the classroom last week,
that had a very interesting
discussion around.
The place in society for
brands that make you feel certain way.
And people maybe some folks here in
the audience, at least others that I know.
Have talked about SoulCycle or
fire will as, another form of therapy,
it's religion, it's like my church.
At what point did that start
to happen where people
would share with you
that type of reaction?
And is that okay for
a brand to fill that void?
>> I think so [LAUGH].
And it happened right away.
And the major reason that people started
to feel comfortable connecting with me
because I can only speak for myself was
because of my willingness to be vulnerable
in front of people and I found that,
if I was vulnerable, it made them feel
comfortable enough to be vulnerable.
And it's when two people
are vulnerable that they connect.
And look,
we certainly know in this day and
age of living the most efficient
life we can and technology and
everything going digital,
it we need to connect more than ever.
I mean,
it's a human need that will never go away.
And so that's why I think this business
is, this type of business is so
important and here to stay.
>> And that's a nice transition
into the industry as a whole.
You got into the health and
wellness space when it was really nascent.
There weren't the SoulCycles and
other brands out there.
Now on every corner in any neighborhood,
especially places like Palo Alto and
elsewhere, but a lot of Metro cities now
you have a million different options.
Health and
wellness is an $80 billion industry.
Where is there space for
innovation, if at all?
>> So it's a good question because,
in thinking about the future of all this.
We're seeing what's happening with the
industry, we're seeing how it is going.
Into the digital realm and look in
spinning we're seeing about the success of
Peloton and
the industry's definitely changing and
with the amount of choices out
there which you just spoke about,
it's very different you know
when I started SoulCycle and
Flywheel those were the days of people
taking six spin classes a week so
you know what a formula for
success in our business is but
now, there's so
many choices I call it exercise snacking.
People are, people are not coming
to spring class six days a week.
They're coming twice a week and then,
they're going to Barry's twice a week.
And then they might be boxing or couple
days a week on their Peloton at home.
And, and
I don't have the answers actually.
It's very interesting to me as to where
this will go and where this will head.
Health and wellness, I think, will always
be a huge industry moving forward because
of the challenges we all
have in life in general and
people are finally starting to recognize
that we need to take care of ourselves and
we want to live long lives and,
and kind of this is how to do it.
But i'm very interested in seeing
where the fitness industry
particularly goes and I do feel
like there will always be room for
the group fitness part
of the fitness industry.
I think people always will need this human
connection that is just spoke about.
The convenience factor
will not go away and
people will want to be able to have the
option of doing it in their home as well.
So I think there will be both.
>> That Peloton story just
fascinates me because.
>> It's fascinating.
>> Here you are taking people out of
their basement stationery bike and
bringing them to their neighborhood gym
and giving them a sense of real in person
community and now 15 years later you have
a company that just went public saying you
know what let's bring you back into your
basement And take you away from the very
thing that you describe people seeking
which is community is that here to stay?
>> Well I'm going to give John Foley a
shout out the founder of Peloton, he used
to be a big Flywheeler and SoulCycler and,
>> But more flywheel.
>> Yes, of course.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
So I actually was just going to talk about
the lawsuit, but I better not [LAUGH].
>> Come on, bring it back.
Sorry I didn't mean to.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Just between us
friends here in the room.
>> This is definitely going to bite me
in the ass some way but, no, I mean,
there is a lawsuit going on obviously
I won't go into the details, but
there is a patent lawsuit going on
against Flywheel from Peloton and
it's just very amusing to me because
John modeled the Peloton bike
after the Flywheel bike so that was a big,
you know, scratch my head moment.
But, but what I was going to say was I was
going to give him a compliment because he,
and we're actually friends.
We really are.
>> Sounds like it.
>> We're on good terms.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Scratch my head moment.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
he at Peloton they actually
did a really good job I think
of bringing the community aspect
into this at home experience.
And I was actually Really impressed and
surprised by it.
But, they have built a huge community at
peloton I'm sure you've all read about it.
And it's part of the reason for
their success I mean,
peloton writers having conventions
basically and getting.
Getting together all over the world.
So he's actually done
a great job of doing that.
But I'm also hearing a lot in in terms
of people missing the group experience,
the live experience,
and wanting it back and
we were actually having this
conversation before I came out here.
But another phenomenon that's taken
place is a lot of kind of the bigger
businesses and corporations are now
getting into this sector and
SoulCycle was acquired,
Flywheel was acquired.
And the businesses have changed a lot
because they've gotten more corporate and
they've gotten less personal.
And I've heard a lot of complaints about
that from riders at both SoulCycle and
Flywheel that they miss the way it used
to be and they miss the community and
the attention that was given to
the individual because it's been lost.
And so that kind of speaks to wanting
to bring it back full circle to
a certain degree.
>> To bring the conversation back full
circle, one of the things we spoke
right before coming on stage about was
what lessons you would give yourself
as a teenager thinking about the course
of your life as an entrepreneur,
the business takeaways,
you described some of them.
But also we have a lot of business
school students in the audience now and
a big reason people come to programs like
View From The Top is we're about to go in
a lot of different ways.
And I think the power
of storytelling is that
there might be a nugget you can share
that maybe tomorrow, maybe in five years,
or ten years, you look back on it, and
think that was actually really helpful.
That was something, I remember that
story I heard in Ruth's narrative.
Is there anything that you
want to make sure you get out,
if there's one thing folks can take home?
>> Yes,
that question is often verbalized by
saying what would you tell
your 16 year old self and
that's how I'm looking at it.
And if I could do that and
if I could go back,
the message would be to
relax that we're not
going to have the answers when we're 16.
We might not have
the answers when we're 37,
but we put so
much pressure on ourselves in thinking
that we should know the answer and
we don't.
And I think the comforting piece of
it is that every decision
we make as we evolve and
grow up actually does play a part
in where we ultimately land.
And as I was talking before
about my dance classes,
I thought I was going to be a dancer.
That idea fell through and at the moment,
when it fell through,
I felt like nothing but a failure.
And I was clueless as to
what I was going to do next.
And again, at that moment,
I had no idea what a huge part my
experience with dance would
play in my future career.
And so again, it's just everything
happens for a reason as trite as that is.
But it really does, and
we learn an enormous amount with
every decision we make along the way.
And there really is no wrong decision.
>> If it's okay, I'd love to end
with a personal question that
I think you touch on a little bit, or at
least led me to want to ask in your book.
You describe a very close
relationship with your father,
who I believe passed away from cancer.
>> Yeah.
>> And
you describe a scene where
you were at his bedside.
And he said to you that and
I quote, I'm ready to go.
I've accomplished everything
that I ever set out to do and
have enjoyed my life fully.
And then you respond by saying that,
quote,
in that moment as much as I couldn't
help feeling my own sorrow,
I was also inspired by his courage and
his resolve.
A lot of times death makes us think
about our own mortality in certain ways.
What did that have on you as you
think about the rest of your life?
>> Honestly, I'm looking forward
to the rest of my life and
everything that's happened thus far,
everything that will afford me
in terms of my experiences.
But that was a moment
where I really thought
I just hope one day I can say that about
myself and I already feel like I can.
So that feels really good.
>> Thank you, Ruth.
Let's go to questions.
I think we have a few from the audience.
They were presubmitted.
>> Okay.
>> Hi Ruth.
>> Hi.
>> My name's Dan Knapp,
I'm a first year MBA student.
And I was wondering if you could talk
a little bit about some of the leadership
principles or lessons that you took from
being an instructor on the podium and
you carry it into the board room as a CEO.
>> Yeah, I think I would answer that by
again going to back to the empathy piece.
And I like to share with people that
going into business, I had absolutely no
business experience, and
I was raised in a family of physicians.
And surrounded by my parent's friends
who were all from the medical community.
So I really didn't have a clue, and so
when I look back, and
look back at my leadership style,
I think, well, what was my leadership
style and where did it come from?
And the truth is,
my biggest experience was being a mom.
And so
I looked at how I raised my children and
what my style was in raising my children,
and the truth is I
used a lot of qualities that
are typically attached to women.
And empathy is certainly one of them.
And I learned that the simple
idea of the importance
of listening to people
would be very important in business as
well, and listening to my employees,
and listening to what works for
them and what doesn't work for them.
Listening to their despair when they
made a mistake, but then encouraging
them that you can learn from your mistake
and let's see what we can do with that.
Again, typical ways in which I
brought up my children and so,
that was really what I drew upon the most
in terms of my leadership style.
>> Hi, my name is Kanna Hammen and
I'm an MBA one and
I have been to both SoulCycle and
Flywheel many times.
So thanks for
bringing all of us that experience.
You talked about how important it was
to help your clients feel noticed,
and important, and
like they're a part of a community.
I'm curious about other
elements that you wanted
to bring into both of these brands as
you were thinking about the concepts and
how you brought them to life in
the brands that you did create?
>> It was about making people
feel comfortable in every way.
Customer Service, in general, was huge and
is huge in this field and
in this industry.
And that has to do with not
only making people feel good,
but making everything easy for them.
And starting Flywheel was a huge,
sorry, let me rephrase that.
Being second in an industry was a huge
advantage in many ways because I got to
see what worked at SoulCycle and
continue that and what didn't work and
improve upon it.
So a good way to answer the question
is when we started Fly Wheel
we wanted to make sign up more efficient.
At SoulCycle,
literally everyone walked in,
waited on line and
signed up on a list, a paper list.
>> They still do it.
>> And they still do, yes.
Immediately at Flywheel, we thought
we're adding technology to the bike, so
let's be consistent, and let's have small,
portable laptops set up in our lobby area.
So people don't have to wait in line,
and people can sign up by themselves.
At SoulCycle, people had to reach for
their wallet and
pull out some cash for
a bottle of water, and shoe rental.
We made it all inclusive in our price,
so they didn't have to pay for anything.
It was all done already.
They didn't have to wait in line to get
shoes, we had personalized cubby holes and
we saw who's coming to class a head of
time and had their shoes waiting for them.
So again customer service is huge.
Hi.
>> Hi [CROSSTALK]
>> I'm Jen, I'm a first year MBA,
thanks so much for your time.
A question I have is around
something you mentioned earlier.
I think a lot of us,
an ideal state would be to go to Spain,
maybe a few times a week,
Palatine at home.
I think the reality is that's not
accessible just based on different income
levels.
So I'm curious how you think
accessibility can be incorporated
into the wellness industry and
boutique fitness particularly?
>> Great question, and
it's something I'm currently actually
thinking a lot about,
because there's no question,
the boutique industry is really
not very accessible to everyone,.
And I think that that's
really needed right now.
And I know I happened to know of
businesses that are already in
the works where they're coming
up with a less expensive bike
which will then allow a business
that's more accessible.
A less sorry,
a less expensive at home bike as well.
So I know everyone's trying to think
in that direction right now, and
then I think it's so important.
>> Hi.
>> My name is Laura, also in MBA 1.
Thank you so much for being here.
My question was around
the therapy topic you mentioned.
I think it's so
rare to see someone as successful as
you talk about how important it was.
And I'm also a big proponent of mental and
physical fitness.
So I was wondering for
people who maybe haven't tried it yet, or
even people who have,
how would you describe what therapy or
other types of mental
fitness helped you change?
Or come to realize,
you touched on it a little bit, but
maybe if you could talk more in depth
about what are some tangible things to
help people understand what
mental fitness could look like.
>> I'm going to give you
two anecdotes on that.
I had a very difficult marriage.
So my ex-husband had
anger management issues,
we'll just leave it at that.
And I stayed in it for a long time,
way longer than I should have, but
I can't really think of it that way
because it's who I was at that time.
There was a reason why I was there.
And it wasn't until therapy,
in fact, my first therapy
session where I sat down and
my motivation was my father was dying and
I had no idea how I was
going to go on with that.
And within the first session I was asked
about to describe my marriage, and I did.
And it was the first time in my
life that someone said to me,
do you understand that that's
actually unacceptable behavior?
And I think I just broke down in tears.
That was a life changing moment for
me, and
that wouldn't have happened if
I didn't seek out a therapist.
And that really started my ball rolling in
terms of not only leaving the marriage but
starting to really learn
about who I am and who I was.
The second anecdote was another trauma,
it was about another
trauma which was the dissolution
of my SoulCycle partnership.
And I remember probably a year ago,
I mean the dissolution happened in 2007.
It's 2019, and probably a year ago
I sat in a therapy session and
I said to my therapist,
is there something wrong with me because
I can't seem to get past this trauma.
Like I still get really upset and
angry when I think about it.
Is there something wrong with me?
And she looked at me and
she said, why would you ever think
there was something wrong with you?
Why wouldn't you feel that anger today?
It was a horrible, horrible thing.
That was incredibly helpful to me.
Again, just another moment
of putting things, and
being able to put things in
perspective and have self empathy.
A lot of us don't really know that we have
permission to really feel for ourselves.
We've all been through traumas.
We've all had a lot of challenges
growing up, and in our adult life, and
taking a moment and understanding tat and
acknowledging that is huge.
>> So we have one last thing to do
which is somewhat of a tradition here
called the Lightning Round.
>> Yep, you should be scared.
>> That's a lot of pressure.
I am.
>> But I took the liberty to make
a Version two of that game just because
you're here and
I thought it might been fun.
We can see how this works.
It's called who said it best,
Plato or SoulCycle?
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's a very simple game.
So I will say a quote and
you will have the option of saying
is it a quote said in a Soul Cycle class,
or by Plato.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then if you want,
we can then ask the audience to either
kind of ask the audience a question.
They can either affirm or
deny if that might be the right answer.
And then I'l share who said it.
>> Wait,
I have to say one thing before you start.
>> Who's [LAUGH] I asked the same question
I was looking up something before you
>> [LAUGH] No, because that,
that question brought this to mind.
Can I see a raise of
hands of anyone who saw
the Saturday Night Live SoulCycle parody?
Okay, thank you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This was an inspiration for the game.
>> It was so spot on, by the way.
>> Okay, question number one.
Everyone listen up here,
this is important.
Quote, open yourself up to the possibility
that the best part of your life
hasn't happened yet.
Plato or SoulcCycle?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Tricky, right?
>> Mike, I don't know.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Not so easy, yeah?
>> You had to do this in person?
>> When I wrote these down, I actually
couldn't remember who said what,
so I had to back, but
I had the answer here.
Give a guess.
>> Plato.
>> What does the audience think?
>> SoulCycle.
>> It was SoulCycle.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's all right,
it was just a warm up.
>> Clearly I'm not giving him any credit.
>> Yeah, she's got another hour of these-
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I'm just going to, okay.
This is a personal favorite,
nothing beautiful without struggle.
Plato or SoulCycle?
>> Plato.
>> Plato or SoulCycle?
>> Plato, correct, we're one for one.
>> Thanks.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If you're not challenged,
you won't change.
>> SoulCycle.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Correct,
inhale intention, exhale expectation.
>> SoulCycle.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I bet you Plato would have liked that
though-
>> [LAUGH]
>> If that counts for something.
Never discourage anyone who continually
makes progress, no matter how slow.
Plato or Soul Cycle?
>> Plato.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But a little bit of disagreement there.
>> Because I said all of these things.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, exactly.
Duh.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Courage is knowing what not to fear.
Plato or-
>> Plato.
>> [CROSSTALK]
Nice.
And last one,
this is probably the toughest one so okay,
if you don't get this right.
Tap it back.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Ladies and
gentlemen, thank you and let us thank you,
Ruth, for joining us today.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]